welcome to this 15-minute game playing
DS off something like that um from
greece greece greek flag at least all
right here we the kings engine or the
green felt i could play the grid flat
for a change why not one of those
openings that are rarely employed even
on this channel where I play almost all
openings but the Greenfeld is an opening
that I never played in tournament chess
absolutely never not for some quality
reason the diet I don't have any doubt
that this is a good opening it's only
that I never felt like I really knew
what what I was doing that or what I
would be doing that yeah bishop do you
see g7 is an interesting point sack with
III why does not really trying to to
challenge this hmm I wonder now go see
five now yeah probably that's the right
move takes on c5 Queen a five looks very
much like the Bishop f4 line just with
the bishop being somewhat somewhat them
misplaced on g5 at least I hope is it is
misplaced
yes 30 takes d5 looks like they move to
play yeah maybe you can play Knight f3
it's probably not not totally bad i will
probably castle then after Knight f3 Oh
something else entirely yeah 95 isn't
this isn't this good here the capture on
d5 then 25 is certainly good for black
with g5 hanging and d4 hanging and now
this is probably okay already that's the
very nice or one very nice feature of
the ground fault it can easily need to a
very good play for blanket why
displaying some substandard sideline
check yeah not a 96-well why not even
Bishop d7 as possible of course
yeah and there's already quite some
pressure on deform an additional problem
of course is the the bishop on d5 that's
always somewhat yeah somewhat unstable
piece yeah Queen 85 or taking twin a
five let's do that there is a double
attack essentially on the pawn and the
bishop so probably the bishop has to
take on c6
and then I'm threatening commun Texas
recheck and there's also bishop a6
preventing castling probably after takes
takes the right world castle himself
then what not even taking on defaults
not not out of the question yeah I
wonder what exactly why did some
calculating him maybe a move like queen
bee three yarn queen bee three I can't
even play but should be six or queen d3
which also looks a weird not only we are
there probably even Bishop f5 as
possible then yeah why just needs to
take on c6 I believe
check yeah now probably castles yeah
Bishop allowing Bishop a 6 it's not not
a particularly great idea okay one
problem here is that I cannot easily
castle because of the e7 pawn this is a
useful move in almost any case the other
the only thing that okay so he
voluntarily seizes sound the pressure
from e7 good news yeah I mean taking it
as always rook c1 Roxy 5 this is not
really a really helping that much one
more play Bishop b5 here is so very a
valid ID em after that I probably can
cannot avoid the bishop trade maybe
Bishop g4 getting all light lighter
pieces off
yeah Bishop b5 is a move that I would
probably consider and another move that
just that is just saw could be a night
to d2 and tending night b3 and taking on
c5 okay yeah that's also quite quite a
logical idea going to see six
hmm
and it's not not easy to play around
with this week poor now on c6
now officially 7,000 97 here
yeah Queen a 60 son Bishop even Queen f3
okay let's um let's um let's try
something else if I just give up the
pawn on that same my idea is to just
take him the CD formal plate and next
move c5 just opening opening things up
and get rid of the pawn he white might
play knight c6 and win a pawn but i
don't care i just want to open up for
the two bishops and make sure that I
don't have um dominant weakness I rather
give up the pawn rather get up give up
the pawn then being tied to its defense
all the time
Knight takes c6 the risk there is maybe
Quincy five if it takes on c6
traditional idea yeah here thought
Quincy five and where where are you
going Linda's just a good move
the night does not have any particularly
great squares
yeah 90 for this gala besides the fact
that my default it's not really
dangerous and genre grounds but there's
a 5v5 night be three Queens III with a
very good position yeah here I thought
Bishop d7 would be good isn't this good
I don't I don't really understand it 97
27 i'm covering b7 that's not not very
good
yeah I think it's just a piece right I
would just see a defender of the night
white reasons yeah that that was a quick
am quick slope downhill it does that
certainly wasn't there wasn't bad for
white at all I took and yeah he just
needs to take with the horn of course
not 96 yeah and then my original idea
was to play c5 just to give up this pawn
for activity however I'm just seeing
that Jack here there's maybe Bishop b5
toy maybe even the caption hmm yeah
that's certainly very very nice
compensation white can always put this
Bishop he and then everything's nicely
covered got two points I'm not sure
maybe c5 was a wasn't a great idea but I
probably would have played it
yeah so white white is somewhat better
but here it's immediately shifting to a
substantial edge for black the
relatively best is indeed what I briefly
mentioned is this this type of position
which is of course totally uninspiring
for white but at least you're not a porn
down which is exactly what what happened
in the game it should be seven that's
really just over yeah there's some here
actually a bishop f6 is an interesting
more and now there is c6 that leads to
very a crazy complication even c5 is a
move as weird as it looks this kind of
type of ideas interesting yet here we
have to the center and getting opened
maybe Bishop d7 assister better yeah
yeah this structure seems to be quite ok
44 white so maybe it's some improvement
before is handy of course I can try to
adjust better to this idea of 95 which
in this position I didn't really
consider to be played quickly but it was
a good good maneuver putting the 95 he
only blundered afterwards alright thanks
for watching